missions include UK you have the flow
mr. president
honorable members in less than 60 days
United Kingdom is due to leave the
European Union this is a bad decision
please listen
even as the Commission has defended twin
trees of the opinion the spirit of
respect and friendship has accompanied
us at every step in these negotiations
the withdrawal agreement and political
declaration agreed by all 27 leaders and
United Kingdom government is the result
of that the withdrawal agreement remains
the best and only deal possible
European Union said so in November we
said so in December we said so after the
first meeting were meaningful vote in
the comments in general the debate and
votes in the House of Commons yesterday
do not change that the withdrawal
agreement will not be with Nick
renegotiate both sides have said loud
and clear data can be no itten to a hard
border on the island of iron no slipping
back into darker times past I believe
the Prime Minister's personal commitment
on this point but I believe also that we
need a safety net that secures us
against this risk we have no incentive
nor desire to use the safety net but at
the same time no safety net can ever
truly be safe if it can just be removed
at any time sometimes from time to time
I have the impression that some hope
that the 26 other countries will abandon
the backstop and so Ireland at the last
minute but this is not a game
and neither is it a simple bilateral
issue it goes to the heart of what being
a member of the European Union means
Ireland's border is your spot
and in this our unions priority the
ladies and gentlemen we know from
yesterday's debate that the House of
Commons is against many things it is
against a loaded back seat
it is against back slit but we still do
not know what exactly the House of
Commons is actually for the concept of
alternative arrangements is not new it
was discussed in the negotiations it is
referred to in the political declaration
and in our letter to Prime Minister may
Donald Tusk and I committed to exploring
it further as a matter of priority but
the concept is not a plan it is not an
operational solution money in the House
of Commons both among those who voted
for and those who voted against the
amendment are aware of this I will
continue to be in close contact with
Prime Minister may for whom I have the
greatest respect and I will listen to
her ideas but I will also be extremely
clear about the position of the European
Union that I have presented today mr.
president Madame Monsieur president
ladies and gentlemen allow me to tell
you very clearly the yesterday's vote
has further increased the risk of a
disorderly exit of the United Kingdom we
have to continue to do everything in our
power to prepare for all of the possible
scenarios including the worst
the Commission has begun its preparatory
work in December 2017 and in close
cooperation with the Parliament we have
accelerated our preparations
we have been sending teams to every
capital city to ensure that each member
state is ready the Commission will
provide full support to this work and
has done since the beginning
we have had 88 and notifications about
the consequences of brexit in different
sectors we have made proposals on
specific areas such as Erasmus Social
Security and the budget of the European
Union we are presenting these today I
would like to take this opportunity to
thank all of the members of the European
Parliament to ensure that we can get a
rapid agreement on these proposals as
well as on all of the other urgent files
that is in the pipeline it's important
that the European Union remains calm
United and determined as it has been
throughout this process in this work we
have to follow a golden rule
we have to follow the results of the
agreement and at the political
declaration I'm still an optimist by
Nature and they believe in democratic
institutions by conviction this leads me
to believe that I can and will be
agreement with the United Kingdom so
that we can move on and move forward
together with our new partnership we
will work day and night to make it
happen and to ensure that we are ready
in case it does not which ever way I
will always ensure that this house is
the first to know and the last to decide
thank you evander donate a pair or
another now before I give the floor to
our negotiator Michel Barnier what I
wanted to stress to the presence of the
Commission and to our negotiator and to
the Parliament that the solution to the
brexit problem as we see it includes the
defence of the EU citizens all three
million of them who live in the United
Kingdom that is a priority and we also
are concerned about the right of British
citizens who live in the EU so first of
all the rights of British and EU
citizens and those from elsewhere as
well thank you very much she was sort of
crazy dome president thank you ladies
and gentlemen Secretary of State first
and foremost mr. president thank you for
allowing me once again to speak to you
here in the plenary and day after day to
consolidate against next to President
Juncker this climate of dialogue
transparency and confidence that we have
built together with you ladies and
gentlemen members of the European
Parliament and in particular with the
great rector steering group Kiefer
hashset and all the members of the group
over the past year and a half
we've had a meeting pretty much every
week ladies and gentlemen for the first
time yesterday the UK prime minister
Theresa May openly called to reopen the
withdrawal agreement even before the
vote late in the evening she took
distance from the agreement she herself
had negotiated and on which we had
ritchie achieved an agreement the UK
government then explicitly supported the
amendment entered by segrin brady
calling for the backstop to be replaced
that was planned under the Irish
Protocol and to have that replaced by
alternative arrangements which were
never actually defined at the same time
they chained the House of Commons
rejected the No Deal
scenario without clarifying what means
they would take to avoid that scenario
so that is currently the state of play
in terms of this extraordinary and
lengthy negotiation which well because I
was in the front line and under the
authority of President Juncker president
Tuscon yourself it was very serious now
president Yonker remind us what happened
yesterday evening and we share the will
of the UK Parliament to avoid and no
deal I agree with Teresa may voting
against a No Deal as happened yesterday
does not rule out the risk of a no deal
for us ladies and gentlemen the
withdrawal agreement is and remains the
best and only means to ensure an orderly
withdrawal of the United Kingdom and to
implement in an ordinary
mana the sovereign decision taken by the
majority of UK citizens which we respect
that being to leave the European Union
and despite the difficulties were facing
today I believe we can achieve that
objective on the condition that we are
both lucid and realistic and we are
responsible and respectful on both sides
each side with the other ladies and
gentlemen the back stop is mentioned by
President Juncker is part and parcel of
the withdrawal agreement and this
agreement will not be renegotiated the
conclusions of the European Council in
December which are squared with the
resolutions of the European Parliament
leave no scope for doubt on that point
on a backstop briefly just so that
everyone fully understands what we're
talking about the backstop it's not any
kind of dogmatism it is a realistic
solution throughout the negotiations
under your control we sought solutions
to the problems created in particular
but not only in particular in island by
brexit itself and the backstop as its
included in the withdrawal agreement is
the outcome of these extremely intense
negotiations over two years involving us
with the United Kingdom never against
the United Kingdom the backstop is a
pragmatic response to the unique
situation on I on the island of Ireland
after the UK decided in its sovereign
right to leave not only the European
Union but also the single market and
then also the customs union we needed
two years to come up with this solution
which reconciles various different
requirements the first one for all of us
being to avoid at all costs the return
of a hard border in Ireland in other
words to preserve the conditions which
have been in place for the past 20 years
peace stability and dialogue on the
island of Ireland since the Good Friday
and Belfast agreement agreement was
signed and I would recall that the
United Kingdom itself through its own
Prime Minister on several occasions has
confirmed its commitment as a guarantor
of the conditions of that Good Friday
Belfast agreement and for 20 years we
ourselves through the peace programme
European law European policies the
European budget we have supported the
success of that cooperation between the
various different communities that's a
first requirement then the second
requirement is the call from the UK
government to keep northern islands and
you cane in a single customs territory
the third requirement obviously ours the
one for which we are collectively
responsible is to preserve the integrity
of the internal market that is a crucial
point towards ladies and gentlemen the
Irish border because of the UK will is
going to become the border of the EU in
our own internal market it's going to be
one of our a new external border and
what is at stake of course is the
protection of all consumers and
companies in the Union more specifically
still the UK decision to leave the EU
the single market has a practical and
the customs union has a clear result all
goods all animal or plant produce all
live animals going into northern and
from the UK not only entering Northern
Ireland Island but they're also entering
into the single market of that of your
countries and the the safety the the
nature of those products linked to
animal quality and I'm saying this is a
former Minister of Agriculture in my
country that requires checks and those
checks are implemented on all of our
external borders all
around the EU health checks fiscal
checks veterinary checks and regulatory
checks and we owe that protection to the
five hundred million consumers and the
twenty with the UK now and the 22
million companies we owe that protection
to all of those who are in the internal
market for those people now calling to
get rid of the backstop there are
members of the UK Parliament and I heard
some of them saying this morning and
they negotiated with us and they know
perfectly well that this backstop is the
solution we came up with for what is the
very heart the core of ours as Europeans
of our obligations and our principles as
president Juncker was saying in other
words the protection of the internal
market in all of its dimensions all of
the rights social rights economic rights
consumer rights environmental rights and
protection for companies and consumers
so when I hear to some people who who
were even part and part of the
negotiations when I hear them saying
what they're saying it's tough I find it
hard to accept this blame game that
they're they're trying to play against
us
as president Janka has said we will do
nothing it's as simple as that nothing
which would undermine the internal
market nothing which would compromise
the future of the European Union because
of these negotiations and as the
president said we are nonetheless open
to alternative arrangements which were
mentioned yesterday in the House of
Commons the Irish Protocol and the
political declaration mentioned that and
the letter from president Yunker made
that a priority for future negotiations
we're ready to work on that as soon as
the withdrawal agreement is signed but
right here and now quite honestly no one
neither on one side nor on the other can
say very clearly and precisely what form
these alternative arrangements will take
so that they can be operational and so
that they can objectively meet the aims
of the backstop so once again calmly but
clearly I will say right here and now
with this withdrawal agreement as
proposed for ratification
we need this backstop as it is ladies
and gentlemen
rejecting the backstop as it stands
today boils down basically to rejecting
the solution which was found with the
British but the problem remains as I've
already described it for you and on that
point going beyond the alternative
arrangements I mentioned the European
Council and the European Parliament on
several occasions have already clearly
rejected the idea of having a limit in
time or a leaving unilateral
unilaterally the backstop because that
would undermine the very idea of the
backstop it's an assurance we don't want
to use it
well these your own insurance for your
house or your apartment or whatever we
don't want to use it but it will be
there if we need that insurance
finally the withdrawn agreement we're
talking about that you're very familiar
with goes well beyond the question of
island
this agreement ensures the rights of
more than four-and-a-half million
citizens President Diana you talked
about the priority of the Parliament
it's ours as well and whatever happens
that priority to secure the rights of
citizens and compatriots
three-and-a-half of them living in the
UK from our different countries of
course and the rights of one and a half
million UK citizens in our countries
securing those rights is our priority we
have to protect the beneficiaries all of
them of the European budget in the 28
countries the commitments we entered
into in 2028 have to be respected by 28
a 21-month transition period in the
course of which administration's and
companies on both sides will be able to
prepare themselves for this future
relationship and that will give us a
time not long it will be very demanding
but that will give us a time to
negotiate the future relationship in a
new stage of the negotiations so this
agreement is the necessary first step to
build confidence between the United
Kingdom which will remain an ally a
partner a friendly country and the
European Union a real solid ambitious
partnership and I would just like to add
that in respect to this future
relationship the Europeans are ready and
will continue to be ready over coming
days to be more ambitious and to rework
the nature and intensity of our future
relations economic relations in
particular and you know ladies and
gentlemen that there are several models
for economic cooperation with third
countries each of these models obviously
has its own balance of rights and
obligations but there are many different
models if the UK demand were to evolve
beyond a simple free-trade agreement on
which we agreed in the political
declaration to
and they moved towards one or the other
of these models we will be ready to
discuss that immediately and express our
own ambitions in the face of the UK
ambitions we've said that already as you
have in your resolutions as has the
European Council I mentioned lucidity
beforehand and realism as you did Madam
Secretary of State it's less than 60
days now to when the UK is going to
leave but we don't have a positive
majority now in the House of Commons on
a an identify clearly identified
solution accepted by the UK and as
president Janka said it is therefore
urgent that we should be prepared for
all scenarios and we should bring in all
contingency measures which are more
essential than ever and that's what the
secretary has been called upon to do by
president Janka who's working with you
and all of your teams thank you very
much for your attention and for your
confidence will Monsieur bunnyville
thank you very much very much mr.
Bernier you can count on the support of
the European Parliament the first
speaker is mr. Elmar Brok on behalf of
the EPP group president mr. president
president in office commission president
Shelburne yay dear colleagues I would
like to begin by thanking jean-claude
juncker and Michel Barnier for the good
cooperation the genuine transparency
that they've shown the information they
have given us and the ability to listen
in this process it's a good example of
cooperation on top of this our awareness
that we continue to support this
negotiating strategy we saw the vote in
the House of Commons yesterday all the
positive constructive proposals were
rejected the only thing people agree on
is this proposal that may has made for
the third or fourth time now which is to
go back to Brussels and renegotiate the
backstop
there's nothing new that has been agreed
it's vital really that the head of the
government and the leader of the
Opposition have not been speaking to one
another in a period of three years if
you are leaving you need to know what it
is that you want before you bother other
people with this so please come with a
unified position attractive idea and
come back to Brussels that might be an
important question talk to each other we
are United you are not United within the
government within the Tory Party within
the Labour Party that's the main problem
benzene here is in him what we see here
is there is a negative majority consists
consisting of various positions which
range from the hard brick sitters to the
remainders and you can negotiate it as
much as you want the ones who want a
hard break or hard breaks it won't agree
and the people who hope that at the end
of the day they'll stay at the end of
the day it won't work because they'll
reject everything that isn't another
referendum so in this situation we can't
achieve anything for this reason it
won't be possible to reopen the
discussion on the backstop witnesses may
you have to understand that your country
is a member of the European Union and it
was thanks to a large degree to the
right to being in the EU that the Good
Friday Agreement could be achieved
via Verdi svet ID and we will defend to
this agreement we will defend the peace
program we don't want a hard border and
you yourself said you don't want a hard
board you said you know a back stop was
necessary to we will defend the good
fight agreement and resist having a hard
boy border the backstop that we have now
with the customs union was invented by
the British it was a British proposal
the European Union had made other
proposals to achieve this so now the
British want to renegotiate something
that they proposed themselves in the
first place I mean I think this is a you
know quite crazy so you in London have
to sit down together and talk to each
other and decide what it is that you
want first and well we have withdrawal
agreements you have a transition period
in which all sorts of things can be
arranged all sorts of things can be
sorted out trade zone or Swiss
arrangement in Norway arrangement
whatever you want and then you wouldn't
need the backstop it's clear that the
backstop won't be necessary if we sort
out the arrangements during the
transition period so please get things
sorted out get things that get these
things clear
it's natural of course that we should
have to carry on with our preparedness
proposals of course natural that we are
still open to discussions you don't want
a hard break SID we don't want a hard
break sit I don't want to break sit at
all I just to be absolutely clear but
it's for the British to decide
we have to accept that and we want to be
there in order to limit the damage as
much as we can possibly do for both
sides one thing I think the British
population should know is that the
damage will be much greater to the UK
the European market is 14 times bigger
than the British and all of these
companies that want to produce for the
EU market are going to leave the UK is
going to be a bitter hour for the UK a
bitter hour for all of us so please get
together talk sensibly to one another it
means first of all that the British have
to arrive at a sensible and constructive
position first
excellent German from the British bench
there thank you we move now to our next
speaker on my list here mr. gaultieri
for the Alliance of socialists and
Democrats Thank You president mr.
president the Commission dear Michelle
it is difficult to deny that we are
facing difficult grave situation and
that the risk of New Deal has increased
the House of Commons has voted it
rejects an ordeal brexit which is good
but at the same time it has asked to
replace the Northern Ireland backstop
with alternative arrangements which is
clearly not a workable option we have
seen with surprise the same Prime
Minister who just a few days ago said
that the best backstop was an essential
part of the best deal possible now
calling for its replacement this might
have temporarily reunited a political
party but has not provided any positive
solution to the brexit deadlock we have
therefore to explain again why this
Parliament and the European Council in
their mandate to the you negotiator have
made clear that an operational
and legally-binding backstop is an
essential pillar or withdrawal agreement
and that we will not give consent to any
deal without it preventing a hardboard
and in Ireland and protecting the peace
process is not a partisan position and
the the single market integrity is a not
negotiable three principle for the
European Union the backstop is a
guarantee an option of last resort it is
necessary to ensure that if an agreement
on the future you UK relationship is not
concluded by the end of the transition
period the minimum essential safeguards
will be in place to keep the border open
while safeguarding the integrity of a
single market it is worth to recall that
the backstop has been modified at the
request of the UK government and it was
not an easy concession from the EU's
side we did it to allow Northern Ireland
to remain part of the same customs
territory as the rest of the UK avoiding
tariffs quotas of checks on rule of the
region within it and we did it
notwithstanding the fact that our
original proposal of Baxters was simple
fair and did not impose any material
border in the Irish Sea the only
positive message from yesterday's vote
is that the UK Parliament rejects a new
deal brexit this is welcome a No Deal
would be bad for everybody but a
disaster for the UK it is right that MPs
made clear that this is not acceptable
so what's next we have always said and
we repeat today that we want to see as
close a relationship as possible between
the United Kingdom and the European
Union it was the UK red lines that has
made this impossible so far it means
deaths for us the only alternative to
the backstop is a closer you
UK relationship if you want to ensure
that the backstop is never used build a
positive majority for a more ambitious
relationship a custom union at at least
a closer alignment to the single market
we are now less than two months away
from the UK leaving the you we urgently
need to see positive proposal from the
UK on how to break this deadlock if
Parliament is unable to do this then it
should be put back to the British people
if the UK needs more time we are open to
it but we need a clear plan or proposal
on how it will help resolve the issue
we cannot allow more time for blaster of
false promises we are united strongly
United come firm behind our negotiator
we will continue to follow the clear
mandate given both by European Council
and the European Parliament and so it is
right that on the basis that is unity we
have to be worried but we can be also
optimist thank you thank you mr. Fox for
the conservatives and reformists group
and please show respect to the speakers
mr. Coburn that was directed towards you
Thank You mr. Fox I hope he shows you
respect thank you madam president
I've heard five speeches this afternoon
described the efforts made to negotiate
the withdrawal agreement and how good it
is but I'm sure you will all have
noticed that this very withdrawal
agreement was rejected two weeks ago in
the House of Commons by an overwhelming
majority so now is not a moment for
rhetoric but for reflection it was never
going to be easy to disentangle the
United Kingdom from the European Union
but there is now a clearer road ahead if
we choose to take it I know there are
some here Elmar Brok still hoping that
the UK will stay in the Union and at
taking positions based on that hope but
this is not going to happen it would be
wrong in principle to ignore the
referendum result and in practice it is
clear there is no majority in the House
of Commons in favor of such a course the
amendment designed to secure a second
referendum was withdrawn as it had so
little support the British government
and the House of Commons wants to leave
the EU in an orderly manner and with a
deal and to achieve that we need to
change how the protocol on Northern
Ireland operates we must do all we can
to support the Good Friday Agreement but
it is a paradox that the backstop whose
purpose is to avoid a hard border may in
just 58 days time be the cause of
creating such a hard border in the
island of Ireland let me repeat the
backstop in its current form will not
prevent a hard order it will create it
let us all pause to consider this it may
be very easy to sit down to great
applause today for a rigid defence of an
existing position history may not be so
kind because as things stand we don't
have a deal there is no deal until both
sides have approved it according to
their law and it is simply not good
enough to repeat ad nauseam that the
deal cannot be amended that leads to no
deal and that leads as the Commission
confirmed last week to a hard border
between the United Kingdom and Ireland
so it is my hope that even at this late
hour changes or additions can be made to
bring a deal safely home as Monsieur
Bonnier said in the event of a No Deal
the EU would find an alternative
operational way
to carry out checks and controls without
putting back in place a border that's a
quote let us look at that now let us
consider whether time limits and exit
mechanisms offer a solution let us
proceed with goodwill remembering that
flexibility and generosity are not signs
of weakness but of strength for what is
at stake is not just the draft agreement
at stake is the future partnership
between the European Union and the
United Kingdom let us ensure that we can
construct a long-term relationship to
promote our common values and our shared
interests in an uncertain world let us
find a way to move forward together
thank you for the Alliance of liberals
and Democrats mr. Hofstra yes after the
vote yesterday
mrs. May announced that she will come to
Brussels and for me I have to tell you
very honestly she's always welcome
certainly here in the European
Parliament should be good that she comes
one to the European Parliament here as
we requested already more than a year
ago but the question today is naturally
for what for what to do what is it to
change the red lines that the British
government has used from day one that
could be a breakthrough I think that
could change effectively the outcome of
of this whole process or is it that's my
second point what will be our mandate
because for the moment I have to tell
you mr. Fox I have also yesterday not
see a parliament that gives a clear
mandate to tourism a we have
seen a vote against a number of things
against D deal against no deal against
the backstop but until today more than
two years the House of Commons has not
voted one proposal in favor of something
in favor of a relationship between the
EU and UK never the last two months I
have to tell you have be very exhausting
very exhausting not only at the other
side of the channel also here endless
debates long list of amendments
amendments going in all directions
selected by the speaker and then won and
lost with the teeny-tiny majority I gave
here the list de Greve amendment that
was the fourth of December that was for
a remain amendment worn by 22 votes the
Cooper amendment also remain amendment
that was of the 8th of January one with
seven votes there another Cooper
amendment that was yesterday lost by 23
votes then the Brady Amanda man that was
more a leaf amendment 1 by 16 votes
yesterday and then again a remain Amanda
man the spellman amendment and to take
the No Deal from the table 1 by 8 folks
is that the way you can solve a problem
of a magnitude is that the way to do
that is that the way you do that there
is everyday changing your opinion every
day changing your opinion and in any way
creating an uncertainty and instability
instead of concluding a real new
relationship between the EU and UK and I
have to tell you I am looking to that
and I cannot understand it that what
started as a catfight inside the
Conservative Party is today and
Stan's a problem for the whole Britain
and like yesterday voting for example
the spellman amendment with the majority
of eight votes saying the no deal is off
the table and then the Prime Minister
coming back five minutes later and
saying no no no no no that's what's for
joking and that we did that but No Deal
is still possible I have to tell you we
cannot go further like that this is a
lack of clarity than a lack of stability
and I hope one thing that is at this
moment is happening as we speak a
meeting between the leader of the
Opposition mr. Corbyn and the prime
minister mrs. may I hope that will that
they will decide or that they will
discuss content and that is not only
eating biscuits and drinking D this
afternoon because it could be the
solution for this problem if they start
to working together on a cross-party
approach so that we know what the
position of the UK is in the future
because we don't know it putting in fact
putting in facts mr. Fox putting in fact
country before party telling is how DC
that future relationship between the EU
and UK and not using or abusing brexit
as it happened also to get rid of each
other because that is what happening
today and if that is the spirit that
emerge in Downing Street this afternoon
then the Prime Minister may can come to
Brussels to tell us what is broad stable
majority cross party once as future
relationship and I think also there is
the solution for the backstop because if
there is a close relationship deeper as
Michele Bini has indicated then the
backstop will still exist but it shall
not be necessary to use it it shall be a
theoretical insurer
that in fact is not necessary to apply
again we all ready to go in that
direction Michelle Varney has indicated
jean-claude juncker has indicated it's
time that the political class in Britain
is also ready to go in that direction
the fastest as possible because you
gonna pay the first price of this lack
of clarity our next speaker on my list
is madam Scott Cato for the Greens
European free Alliance madam thank you
very much president Westminster risen is
in meltdown the internal contradictions
of brexit were laid bare last night
brexit was never anything more than a
bunch of slogans it could never be
turned into a coherent negotiating
position as we play out the end game and
the brexit fraud is revealed its
supporters dream up fantasy deals so
that failure can be blamed on Brussels
but we must hold our nerve through this
westminster chaos a majority of UK
citizens know that the best future for
our country is inside the european union
here we can continue to be part of the
world's most successful peace project
and together we can tackle the huge
cross-border issues we face most notably
climate change we are now the majority
and as young people reaching voting age
want to join us in improving our
continent in mutual friendship so our
numbers grow now the tempies have
rejected No Deal the clear choice is
still between the deal negotiated
between the UK and the EU and remaining
in the EU this choice must be given back
to the people the hostility of the
supporters a brexit as we see here to
such a democratic check proves that they
are running scared
because they know as I do that the will
of the British people has changed and
this turned against them and their
brexit chaos
if colleagues if you were in my power
but it's not the word rubbish would be
banned from this chamber I wouldn't
share it with you sir we move to the
next speaker on my list Madame Schirmer
please this is a very difficult issue
for all of us and the least we could do
is respect the person that has the
microphone there are too many and I have
to say on my right interfering with the
debate please listen
it is far too serious an issue for us to
play out in Parliament this is not the
House of Commons colleagues this is a
European Parliament thank you thank you
madam president
well today we discussed within our group
how we should respond to the votes
yesterday and how we could deal with the
current situation for us this is a group
it's really clear we stand behind to the
withdrawal agreement as negotiated that
is the achievable solution it is not the
best thing that you might dream of for
developing a future relationship between
the EU in the UK but clearly with a lot
of effort with loads of resources thrown
at it that is what has been possible for
us to negotiate over the last two years
we have to think whether if we stand
behind the best that we've been able to
achieve together and we can't say oh I
want to pick this out to take that and
add that no that would endanger the
cohesion of the whole package when I
think about our colleagues in the House
of Commons the message I would like to
pass on is that two years ago when we in
the European Parliament adopted the
mandate for the negotiations the mandate
that mr. Bert Bonnier received it was an
important one and we were able to make
clear in the debate how important it is
to defend the rights of EU citizens in
the UK and British citizens in the
European Union but at the same time the
issue of stabilizing the peace process
in Northern Ireland was a key red line
it was not a question of our own
interests it's a question of peace and
stability across the European Union back
in January at the time of the first vote
and in the debate that I saw yesterday
in the House of Commons the impression
that I got is that their British
colleagues don't take us seriously they
don't seem to understand procedures
they're talking as if they are the only
ones who are going to be voting on all
of these changes
no colleagues you also have to talk to
us you have to respond to our positions
because we can't act as if the British
Empire was more important than the
European Union we have our own democracy
you've been part of that democracy to
date I've always very much appreciated
what I've seen of British democracy and
diplomacy but I must say I'm rather
disappointed when I see the pantomime
that's being put before us it's
important that we should be coming back
to principles we need to be looking at
what we want to achieve at the end of
the day rather
and simply walling ourselves in behind
preconceived positions I'm hoping that
the debate between Corbin and Teresa may
we'll actually get some movement into
the situation
I am very open to developing an open
relationship and having a clear
relationship but what we're not going to
go along with in my group at the very
least and I'm glad to see that most of
the other groups of its Parliament see
things similarly we will not accept a
reduction of our employment law or
environmental standards are consumers
standards we do not want to see the
clock turned back on any of these
principles we do not want to see the
Good Friday Agreement no longer being
fully respected we do not want to see a
hard border we will not accept EU
citizens being seen as third country
citizens in the UK
the procedures should not be seen as
discriminatory for them they should be
able to preserve their rights so that's
what I want to say to my colleagues in
the House of Commons I was very pleased
when British colleagues managed to
assert their right to have a meaningful
vote but now they need to also be able
to tell us what they want to do with it
Thank You mr. Fraser
well public opinion indeed public anger
had a big impact on those votes in the
House of Commons yesterday and with it
we've seen a diminution of the risk of a
second referendum for now the prospect
of article 50 being extended taken off
the table and what I hear speakers
despite the spelling amendment saying
today they're worried that the risk of a
no deal has increased you're right it
has but not because of what happened
last night in Westminster but because of
the response gentlemen we got from you
this afternoon you know even when the
Prime Minister actually gets a majority
behind them and all right I accept
she made a dreadful mistake by signing
up to the backstop you summoned them at
4:15 in the morning she left down a
Downing Street she went to meet the
ultimatum that you'd said sir she signed
up to something that has proved to be a
disaster she signed up to something that
no country unless it had been defeated
in war would have signed up - we now
realise that mistake and actually the
House of Commons the country is overall
looking for a deal but you know
something before the referendum no one
knew who the European Commission were
that Maoist Barroso was a complete
unknown you guys and our household names
and what we've seen is an appreciation
in Britain that
unelected bureaucrats in Brussels have
been talking down to and humiliating the
Prime Minister of our nation and we
don't like it and even when she comes
back trying to be reasonable saying
let's renegotiate you're not prepared to
give an inch
the reason that
No Deal breaks it's got a little bit
closer it's because of the sheer
language and attitude not just from the
Commission but from many in the
parliament towards the United Kingdom I
think public opinion will be very very
angry that there is no give today from
anybody in Brussels whatsoever I think
many will say we're simply dealing with
fanatics who were not prepared to be
reasonable and make any sense of
compromise and of course Teresa may has
made compromise after compromise way too
many compromises in my view so that we
are beginning to think that the public
will come to a view that no deal is
better than the backstop and that's a
big problem it's a big problem for all
of you who want to get reelected in a
few weeks time because no deal means no
39 billion and your voters will be
coughing up the money
No Deal means the hundred million
bottles of Prosecco we buy every year
from Italy will become more expensive as
will three-quarters of million German
cars so why don't we all prepare
sensibly for a No Deal scenario why
don't we prepare to go to the World
Trade Organization use article 24 so
that we can after we leave on March the
29th have a two year period of no
tariffs no quotas no restrictions of any
kind no problems or difficulties with
Ireland whatsoever brexit will have been
delivered you will have protected for at
least two years your voters that I think
ladies and gentlemen right now is the
only possible constructive way forward
mr. button thank you madam chairman the
last two and a half years have been a
long and tedious series of spurious
impediments put up in order to prevent
us leaving and the European unique as
exemplified by the classic backstop bull
the House of Commons rejected the
so-called deal and sent Mrs May back to
renegotiate with a commission that has
already told us but it don't renegotiate
the Commons may have rejected the
amendment to extend article 50 but it
knows very well that the withdrawal Act
itself allows that date to be put back
and the Council of the European Union
can extend article 50 if it so agrees
will we actually leave on the 29th of
March or will the British political
establishment manage to overthrow the
result of the referendum altogether the
best thing that can now happen is if we
have no deal on the 29th of March and
that we leave under the withdrawal act
and on WTO terms article 50 will have
expired and the treaties will cease to
have ceased to apply if the British
Parliament prevents this happening then
they will have put themselves in open
rebellion against the British people and
that will have profound consequences for
any belief in democracy that is left in
the United Kingdom mr. Wolfe thank you
madam Deputy Speaker today is a good day
for brexit today is a good day for
British democracy because over the past
two years our government has lost its
way instead of negotiating effectively
it compromised weekly the EU wanted to
trap written in a backstop deal that
makes us pay money yet stops us
competing against them on the world
stage the you worked and encouraged
remain collaborators in this house and
Westminster it invited devotees from
Blair to chuckling go mana flowing like
champagne at at Islington remain as wake
the constant negativity stalkers
weakness cowardice division delayed us
but weakness no more
despite this the British people were not
for turning they valued their vote over
project fear they do not fear a WTO deal
but relish an independent future and the
British government has finally caught
the mood and got on the freedom train
they finally understand our desire for
independence our fight for
self-determination our belief in our
nation state by uniting last night the
Conservatives succeeding in releasing
our spirit of belief once more we will
leave the European Union we will have
brexit and we will be an independent
nation once more thank you and now to
conclude our debate I give the floor to
madam chair for the council thank you
thank you madam president
honourable members ladies and gentlemen
should the parameter e process in the UK
lead to a ratification of the withdrawal
agreement hopefully along the foreseen
timeline we will have to move to the
next steps starting with the
implementation this implementation will
have to be kept under close watch so
that it delivers in the interest of
citizens and businesses and contributes
to the trust needed for the negotiations
of the future relationship which are
unlikely to be easy we will therefore
count on your cooperation at all the
stages of these processes in the years
to come thank you very much once again
for your attention thank you madam
colleagues the debate is now closed
the riviera rhythms are - yeah